this course is about creating demand a
lot of people think of this as
traditional marketing but marketing has
changed a lot in the last several years
one way I like to think about it is the
company that has the most paying
customers wins so how do you get those
customers well it starts with having a
great product but that's not enough it
takes a lot more integrated marketing
efforts and that is what this course is
about you're gonna have an opportunity
to learn the core principles that stand
behind demand creation we'll go through
the tricks of outbound marketing which
is really that more traditional side of
marketing you've seen where you're out
trying to find your customers will also
go through inbound marketing where you
want people to find you as well as a lot
on social and then we'll tie the whole
thing back together with a living case
study will you get to really have that
chance to make a marketing campaign go
viral
well what I really hope is that you get
a series of basic skills but that it
also sparks your creativity marketing is
about understanding your customers who
they are and being able to put yourself
in their shoes and taking these
tried-and-true principles that we'll
talk about in the course and using them
creatively to accomplish your company's
goals and I think what I would add on to
that is I tend to look at everything
from a strategic perspective so it's
taking what Donna just described and
really putting it in that framework of
really understanding who your target
audience is understanding what it is you
want to accomplish with that audience
and then really looking at where do they
live and how do you get that message
into them so it's taking this whole
realm of new tools we have between the
outbound and the inbound integrating
that but also making it a very strategic
approach